paris 2013 dont les cités ghettos
entourée d'un mur d'isolement
les gangs réno maître absolu quel est le
but de prendre mes sauts quand on sait
qu'on n'a aucune chance de la réussir à
vous les jeux désamorcer une bombe
milieu de la pire des banlieues dans
laquelle j'ai jamais mis les pieds
avouez que c'est pas très actif à 23
heures pour monter cette mère ce qui
concerne les lieux on vous a trouvé un
guide les taux transfert
c'est en plus faut travailler en tandem
tu rentreras sinon tu sors ton manuel de
police à regarder à l'apache est dans la
merde
nadal a retrouvé ses bombes docu que ta
gueule quand tous les bons joueurs tu
critiques qu'est ce que tu veux plus te
préviens si tu me touches je veux bien
m'occuper d'elle il apte à seurre et
dames un bon ben ça fait de raison de
rester tout payant
c'est quoi ce truc là j'ai pas un cadeau
tu as ces cinq adolescents mon frère
un truc qui cloche dans son histoire ça
sent l'embrouillé
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous à me faire
chier aux normes
c'était ma bagnole qui est en train de
défoncer la j'ai piqué ce front de mer
tu n'avais plus de freins chum de
réfugiés ont pas mal aiguillé mon gars
ici c'est pas monaco c'est bagdad